regarding uh your former boss
you know story came out with the fact
that you know
uh legendary colombo boss uh carmine
junior persico was a top echelon fbi
informant court records say wow you know
story came out you dealt with them
directly you spend time with them
how much credence you give to this
article this story that article was
insulting it was fabrication i don't
believe it in any way shape or form
daily news should be ashamed of
themselves for putting that on a front
page with a picture of a rat listen
i knew i knew junior very well he was no
informant he was no rat you know i hate
that you know patrick i hate the term
rat because
you know all the internet warriors now
they throw that around like they know
what they're talking about you know
and uh it's a disgrace to even say that
about the guy and listen
i mean he was my boss he also put a
contract on my life when i walked away
you know so he he wasn't happy with that
with that move but
uh
absolute
absolute nonsense i'll read it to you it
says official boss of the columbo uh
family
on uh whose side greg scarpa the colombo
capo fbi and foreman and roy lindley uh
de vicio scarpa's fbi handler were
working carmine persico was himself
since decades earlier in the
government's employ as a member of its
top echelon informant program wrote
attorney david shone who submitted the
document in july in a brooklyn federal
court filing aiming at getting his
client one time acting car uh colombo
boss victor or the orena 87 we spent a
lot of time talking about him 87 out of
prison on compassionate release persico
died in 2019 at 85
he served 32 years of his 136 year
probation a prison sentence following
his conviction in the mafia commission
case so
you're saying there's zero credence to
him being a rat no what they're saying
there is greg scarpa who we know was an
informant for 20 some odd years
might have been trying to maybe he got
some information out of persico
personally didn't know that uh he was an
informant
you know scarpa so maybe some things
coming from persico were going through
scarpa to the government not with
persecutors knowledge you didn't know
that by the way kai do you have the
chinchigante comment from uh uh from uh
uh uh uh what do you call it rudy if
you're not from what sami and michael
said because
rudy said something different about the
chin i don't know if you have it is this
the one or it's a different one
this is the one okay so we talked about
chin and you know the chin's of power
all that stuff rudy had a different
thought i'm curious what you have to say
about what rudy said if you want to play
kai
were going to do a big raid
and we were going to arrest the number
one or number two people in each family
they did that about two weeks before
well chen giganti
who thought he was number two in the
japanese family but he wasn't
because everybody hated him
they told him he was number two it was
like number eight
chin is the guy who walked around the
robes and acted like he was crazy well
he was crazy he was a
borderline personality disorder in the
military he was actually i think
officially
officially uh diagnosed as a paranoid
schizophrenic he was yeah somebody but
he played he played it up
so
this information comes out
one of the issues comes in until you
can't believe this
chin checked himself in austin
he thinks we're going to arrest him
can be very disappointed when we don't
read
did you end up with the award eventually
but not for that i got it we're not for
that so it it it displayed to the whole
world they've been they've been lying to
him for several years tell you send your
number two you're number two now yeah i
wanted to yes again since crazy don't
listen to [ __ ]
wow fat tony knew he was nuts so he made
him think he was number two but he never
he said how come i don't go to the oh
come on i don't go to the
to the to the commission meetings i'm
number two they say you know chin you're
too high profile
with that bad throat but all that stuff
if they see you walking in they'll know
where we're having the meetings
thoughts i have to disagree with that
really yes why is that kai can you pull
up a picture of this guy
shinjukanti shin was number one shin was
number one absolutely he was the real
power behind the genevieve's family did
you ever have a dealing with him or i
did how was he as an individual
you know
we walked down houston street together
and uh he was in his bathrobe hair
mussed up he didn't shave go back
slippers bathroom but he was as lucid
and as intelligent as anybody could be
you know my father was thrown out in the
military being a military being paranoid
schizophrenic with homicidal tendencies
now was my dad maybe the homicidal
tendencies but
but he wasn't schizophrenic uh so listen
you know people ask me all the time was
chin really you know
goofy and
listen to play goofy for 30 years you
got to have a little bit of craziness in
you but he was he was sharp as opposed
to do you think that was a ruse he was
putting on a ruse 100 percent really 100
percent
100 ruche they they have hours and hours
and hours of taps in there so he they
explain how how that guy could get that
that wrong he
i don't know where he got that
information from i don't know and look
even fat tony i mean fat tony was the
boss so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]